تخوف المرشده الايراني وخلقه اللم ياتي من
فراغ اظهرته وثقام مسربه والوثائق المسربه
تتوالى وتماما كما فعلت الاحتجاجات براس
النظام بنفسه الاختراقات الالكترونيه تظهر
مدى هشاشه النظام السيبراني في ايران
هاكرز بلاك ريبورد الذين سبق لهم اختراق
هيئه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه الان
اخترقوا وكاله انباء فارس وتحديدا نشره
سريه مكونه من 123 الصفحه والتسريبات
دائما تكمل روايه السلطات غير الكامله هل
نعلم ما هو عدد المتظاهرين في الشارع في
العالم اقل من 40,000 شخص اما في الخفاء
قائد الحارس الثوري حسين سلامي يقدر العدد
بي 60
البسيج قواتها بنائيه التي تحفظ له السلطه
في العالم نجحت اما في الخفاء فشلت ابي
كسر باس المحتاجين بل وسنظفت وهنا الحديث
اللي خامنئي المرشد غاضب ومتوتر تكتيك
الدراجات الناريه للبسيج باقتحان مناطق
الاحتجاجات وتنفيذي الاعتقالات نجح في
2009 لكن تبدو الصوره مغايره الان رقعه
الاحتجاجات تتوسع في اكثر من 120 مدينه
سوره المسدج مهتزه في اعين خامنئي
النظام نعم كما ذكرنا قبل قليل للصديق
والشقيق الابواب مو صداقه عذاب واحد الكرم
اثر مسيرات الايرانيه بدا واضحا في
اوكرانيا فرد الدين واجب المخابرات
الروسيه زودت السلطات ابي نتائج تنصت
اجهزه غربيه على ايران لكننا نتائج التنصت
ليست جيده الايرانيون في حاله ثوره النظ
في فوضى الحكومه مرتبكه والمواطنون لم
يعودوا يخشون القوات العسكريه والشرطه
هكذا تسير تسريبات
[موسيقى]
الصلاه
همم ما شاء الله
عز وجل